Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to what just might be the greatest video I have ever made on this channel.
Yes, it is time to play those time-honored Spongebob games that we all know and love.
Actually when I was playing the meme video, uh heh,
(Cough)
or when I was making the meme video, I didn't expect there to be so many Shrek related games.
All I expected was that I was gonna play some stupid games, and those were the ones that popped up, so I was thinking about..
uh...
Another.. legacy on my channel is, ah,
(chuckling) All of the spongebob games that I've played, so I have collected
as many Spongebob-related, both horror and non-horror games that I could possibly find,
and it turns out they're only horror ones.. and, uh...
These are the types of games that remind me of, like, Spongebob Slendypants
Which if you remember I played that oh, so many years ago (laughs)
Oh, man, and then just recently, 3 a.m. at Krusty Krabs.
ANYWAYS,
This is SpongeBob's day of terror, the first one to kick us off.
YOU, Spon- (Spongebob)"I'm Ready!"
(off-guard Markimoo)
uhhh.. okay? YOU, Spongebob, are tra-
*sudden spoopy Spongebob soundtrack*
(also alliteration)
Trapped in rock bottom. Hello? Oh, I don't have money. Safe zo-
(OML MARK WHAT IS IT)
oH
Well I don't like the sound of this.
oOohH
huh, Oh that looks...
that's a nasty patty.
Oh, that don't look so good to me (chuckles)
What the- huoho
IS SOMEONE TRYING TO SELL ME SOMETHIN'?!
WHUOW hey hey hey hey wait a minute here
What the wh-what (marki are confusion)
Uhh hi-hehehe how ya doing
(Mark starts laughing) (Spongebob) This is harder than I thought
(Mark among laughter) What???
(Don't worry we're all confused)
(Spongebob) I'MMM READDYYY
WHAT HAPPENED??
wHaT
I don't hehue- I DON'T UNDERSTAND
ORDINARILY THAT GUY JUST WANTED TO TALK TO ME!
Oh Kelp chips, great! I got some... Kelp chips-
(Mark this is the first game)
oH (again?)
That don't sound good, someone's fartin' up a storm behind me- (Laughs)
what the hell, he just ties it to my wrist? (yes) Augh ok, whatever, you know what?
augh
OH
oHhHh
oHH
Okay, I guess I'm safe. Oh I see
(Mark keeps laughing)
Hi, let me wave to you!
HELLOOO!! HOW ARE YOU DOING??
HELLOO?
OH HI FRIEND!!
Okay, you're gone. I've waved him into - INTO NONEXISTANCE
oh
God, this might be the greatest game. I've ever played-
SUNGLASSES?!?!
FUCK YEAH I'LL BE COOL (Mark prOfAniTy)
uh oh
Well that's not good
HU-HU- Wait a minute
BACK UP THERE
BACK UP THERE SONNY JIM,
I'm in my safe space
hmm (What is it Mark?)
Okay, alright, well fine (Laughs), oh god
This might just be the greatest game I've ever played in my life.
-OhHhhh spatula
that looks... valuable.
uh oh
Well, this is a problem for me. Hey. Hey, HEY WAIT A MINUTE
NO I JUST GOT ENOUGH MONEY
I got enough money for a ticket, don't- no go away! Oh, okay, he went away.  You just got a wave at him, and thats all you need to do
(Laughs)
ah Geez (Rick)
so uhm.. oh... hi.
alright (Laughs again)
Can I have a ticket ple-OH
(Wowit'sabus.png)
Wow
Okay, what? Is that good? Did I make it out? Oh? Hey? How's it going? Can I can I get out of here? Oh?
YeAH
oh my god (laughs)
That was amazing! Everybody give it up
ah, ah (kiss kiss kiss) mmmm
ah that was good,
(Among laughter) that was a good experience
ah good, it was surprisingly well-made for what it was
Which was a great game full of promise and hope. All right okay moving on
Okay so, if you were worried about the quality of these games, DON'T WORRY
They only get better from here
(kiss) (ohno)
(game) It's the dreaaam (remix of spongebob music starts up)
What
(Music stops) uhh... ohhhh
(Mr. Krabs) OHHHH
(spongebob music continues)
...ohhh nooo...
(laughs)
(This is going to be a treat)
HUHUHU (Laughing continues)
Ah, sorry, I don't mean to laugh at this. This is obviously terrifying..  (laughs)
*Spongebob's Brazilian Voice Actor laugh* (Oh Dear)
(Static)
What the fuck??? (Laughs)
Spongebob (in Portugese): Squidward???
Spongebob: Squidward??  Mark: HUHHHH??
Mark: WHAT THE FUCK??
Spongebob (in Portugese): can't find Squidward anywhere...
(Mark in choppy Portugese): "Where is Squidward??"
OHHH..AH!
Okay, I have no idea what's happening.
Oh
Hi- what- PATRICK?
Oh, it's a Five Nights at Freddy's game!! (Oh our favorite) oHhH
Ah
oh
ah
That's to look behind me I guess?
This is- OH
(laughs)
Oh whats that on the- uh oh that's not good
well alright then (laughs)
I can't- oh Patrick's taking a dump
(Disbelief.png)
OOOOO heuhehehe
Oh no, I can't see ANYthing
Oh what am I gonna-
Mark: WOAH
Mr. Krabs (in Portugese): HELLO I LOVE MONEY!
HIII....
OH
(Beginning of Mark's crash)
(literally says ''end of the game'')
oh okay.. (laughs)
(Spongebob laughing again)
(Looking at the top) Mark: Made by official idiots
Oh my god, (Sniff) this is the greatest thing I've ever seen
Okay, let's try to take this seriously, huh? Let's try...
(Laughs anyways)
oh boy, I think I'm supposed to put my mask on when that happens because otherwise
(Giggles)
Otherwise I'll be in trouble, right?
(More disbelief)
Why could I see Patrick on the pooper?
WHAT GOOD IS THIS GONNA DO ME?
WHAT GOOD IS ANY OF THAT GONNA DO ME? I DON'T KNOW, I don't understand
(None of us do, Mark)
Okay now, Patrick's on the pooper. I gotta watch out for Mr. Krabs, I guess,
I su- I suppose. Alright whatever, you know what
(Mr. Krabs is that you?) AHH!
I'M FNOT SPONGEB- awww, I don't know how to play this game
(laughs)
What, do I gotta turn around?
Why did spongebob get exploded in the juice all over the screen?
Is that, gonna make him go away with this I guess?
That would cover him I- I guess I don't know. You know what, I don't know man. I was just guessing here
Alright, here he comes
HAHA, No can't OH, that's how you do it?!!?
OHHHH
Well this is much easier than I thought it'd be
(Wrong.wav)
I thought I needed some complex timing or something- OH OH
Patrick's out of the pooper
EUGH
(Itoldyou.gif)
I'M READY FOR YOU, PATTY BOY!
uh oh. YAYEE
Why are you spea- WAAh
NO! AhhHha I GOT YOUR NUMBER NOW
all right
Easy enough, I guess so long as no one sneaks up behind me
But I don't know why they would do that, that seems awfully, ruuude
alrIGHT! (Jumpscared)
WHAAAAAAAAAAATT
I DIDNT EVEN GET A CHANCE
UGHHHH
(Jumpy jump iminent)
(Gibberish from Mark) OHHOHKAY
(Screaming continues in intervals)
(Tries to shoo Patrick away)
Go away!
*freezes*
Mr. Krabs: HELLO I LIKE MONEY
OHHHHHH
(What just happened)
Okay, you know what, I'm thinking this ain't worth it-
(Realizes irony of that statement)
I think it ain't worth it. This game might actually be broken soooo, maybe there's no point in actually trying to uh beat it
(Dances a bit) ya'll havin' fu- (Laughs)
ALRIGHT MOVIN ON!
(BOAAAAT DOOOOGGGG)
(Sighs a breath of accomplishment)
ah okay it's back now, sorry I took a boat dog break (laughs)
Okay wait, hang on, okay, alright
Everybody
hold on
(Couldn't even understand this... "goddamn arson"?)
I have no idea what's happening
(phone rings)
HELLOOO
(Get ready for pure gold)
(phone rings)
(Phone picks up) (Here it cometh)
(Imagine the most gender-neutral voice you can think of. Raise the pitch by a few octaves, add in a sprinkle of pedophilia, and cover your ears in toilet paper. That's what this guy's voice sounds like.)
(Phone... guy?): Hello hello hello
(Mark breaks)
(Guy on the phone): welcome to your new summer job at nick world! (Mark in background laughing)
Now I'm jusgonna have to read down a few policies [sic]
(Mark laughs)
(Guy coughs)
(phone movement noise)
Phone person in faint voice: Property or person, upon discovery,
(What in the goddamn is this)
...the damage
(Mark is confuzzled) (Phone thing sighs)
Phone entity continues: ...or death ("sounds rude"? idk)
(More confusion)
(laughs) what?
(Cursed image)
(mark continues to laugh)
(Slowly turns into weeping)
(Spongebob shows up) (Mark laughs even more)
(Spongebob laughs) Patrick: NO, THIS IS PATRICK! (squidward screams) (mark keeps laughing)
(Basically, Insanity.)
(The Markiplier slowly loses his sanity in this environment)
(Sandy starts singing about Texas)
(There is no escape for the Markiplier)
(It begins to pain him)
Mark: I'm sorry-
(Cut off by Squidward screaming again)
(Mark loses it)
(Squidward keeps screaming)
(We are witnessing a murder here ladies and gentlemen)
(Like I said, pure gold)
(Mark continues to be hysterical)
Patrick: NO, THIS IS PATRICK
Mark: (Whimpers) oh my god..
uhhhoo (laughs) (Sandy starts singing again)
Phone guy: It's amazing how long the human body can live without the ass
(laughs) Mark: WHATT DID YOU SAY??
Phone guy: Okay, I hope every... thing goes well
Mark: wAIT WAIT WHAT DID YOU SAY?
(We all know what he said)
IM DEAD.
I guess, OH. I reset it. OH GOD I GOTTA GO THROUGH THAT CALL AGAIN
(laughing and weeping combined)
Phone guy: Hallo, hello hello
welcome to your new job at nick world I'm za- gonna have to read out some policies
(Mark mocks phone guy) I'm za-gonna (laughs)
oh oh oh oh
(Breathing exercises, Mark)
oof
(Power goes out)
aw, pff well, shit
(mark starts laughing again)
Patrick NO, THIS IS PATRICK!
(The mess returns)
Mark: nOohO....
(Spongebob laughs again) Mark: Oh, hai
Phone guy: It's amazing how long the human body can live without the ass
(Mark is dying from laughing )
(Peak moment of his channel) phone voice: I hope everything goes well and you don't die
Mark: Thanks, man
Phone guy: aAaaaAnNnNddd... Look out for Mr. Krabs, he can be a bit more... shall I say.. quirkier
(laughs)
Mark: He's gonna be more QUIRKIER
(English with Mark)
Mr krabs: HeLlO, i lIKe mOneY
(In a "quirkier" fasion)
Mark: oh oh okay
(What is life)
(Laughs) it's his signature catch phrase! I like money
(Squidward screams)
(The return of Brokenplier)
(Sandy starts singing again)
Mark: aaaAAAhhAhhhhh Squidward: aaaAAAhhAhhhhh
(Mark continues to die of laughter) kill me kill me kill me
kil me, oh kill me
(Death won't separate you from insanity Mark)
just kill me
(Sandy starts singing again) (Squidward continues to scream) OH GOD MAKE IT STOP
MAKE IT STOP
(Squidward stops screaming) Okay, alright, okay, alright
(Squidward starts screaming again) (Not alright)
Mark: AWW COME ON
(laughs)
(More screaming)
IM DONE! LEAVE ME ALONE!! LEAVE ME ALOoOooNeEEeE!!!!
Oh God, that is a big mood though (what?). Oh man, okay.
(Let's go over what just happened)
WHEW. Okay, all right, so
(Smacks lips)
There you have it. Three wonderful (Hellish*) wonderful spongebob games mmm
MMMM Wonderful, absolutely darling
Imma leave thi- (Laughs some more)
(Yes this happened)
I'll leave the links to these games in the description below if you would like to see them for yourself, please
Check them out. They're well worth their time
So thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought down the comments below, and if you've got other
Games you'd like me to play, maybe a collage of a style of game. Let me know in the comments below
Thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video
buh-bye!
(The demons say goodbye to you)
(This is why we are mortal)